how're you guys doing doing excellent uh
so I really enjoyed the show I was
constantly doing WTF after like every
episode so talk a little bit about that
how have you been describing it to
people because every episode there's
like a peel back of the onion WTF is
that we yeah yeah art to describe this
we show here not a flat-out comedy and
it's not a drama and it's dark comedy
but it's different but not what do we
call it a trauma trauma because there's
people going through trauma but it's
there's an ad e at the end of it and
then few suspense suspenseful
suspenseful and sad sadness but
happiness and some happiness it's a lot
of things the happiness is layered
underneath with a lot of sadness yeah
under this but that's like life you know
when you're going through something
terrible somehow you know your sense of
humor saves you you to have great
chemistry right now but also great
chemistry on the show how long that you
have you guys been friends or hung out
before the show you just met we met one
time before yeah we went to lunch with
Liz Feldman we were already in so I
didn't like each other we were gonna be
there yeah we were get in trouble
Jessica album who's their executive
producer and Lewis Feldman who created
the show and showrunner and we went to
lunch and that was the first time we met
each other and we just looked at each
other and knew I knew who she was and
she knew who I was and we just knew true
it seemed like it was gonna be fun and
that's not like not on an actor II level
like literally like am I gonna be able
to get along with this person yeah
because we're gonna have to go to a lot
of places in the next three months
together you don't have to have trust
and care and support and love and we did
we're gonna have to be able to sit on a
cow
in a drop not drop um I have to ask you
what is it like the night before you're
gonna go sit down and have this meeting
are you a little in your head like oh my
god I hope she likes me or I hope I like
her or are you sort of like what's meant
to be he's gonna happen I'm like do what
I have to take a shower in public she's
shaving my dry I'm gonna be okay if my
hair is like fully dirty and in mom bun
on top of my head you would be you and I
was yeah we talked about that I told you
shower that day actually didn't think I
showered oh the bulk of our covers I
don't like showers I think I'm like
please for me when I spent with Liz
Feldman who runs the show she's like I
want to work with people who want to be
here and I want to work with good people
so um I nice people and to me that's
important you know I think we've spent
our we spent a long time in this career
already both of us and I don't want to
waste my time and an unhappy experience
I want to do good work but I also want
to have a good time so to me that was
something that was very exciting and I'm
making the show and I had heard lots of
nice things about about you when you
when you when Liz is describing the show
to you how much nowadays everything is
all about you know what's gonna happen
next season and thinking about seasons
down the road were you guys pitched on a
plan for where the show could go or is
it sort of like we're gonna make season
one and let's just see what happens we
had she just wanted to concentrate on
for me concentrate on season one I've
only heard that if there is a second
season I kind of know brought some broad
strokes about you know now that we know
I don't know if you saw all ten but now
that we know what do you know yeah
unanswered questions so those will be
answered yeah maybe maybe not or
answered in the way that we answer it on
this show which is really not giving an
answer
because underneath that answer are a lot
of other answers so we're talking about
nothing right so hard to just go right
exactly it's hilarious I'm just gonna
die that no no I think there's a I think
if you know Liz Feldman she's
extraordinary she has just got such a
great mind and great sense of humor and
and I completely trust her I think she
has a lot of ideas of where it could go
I think she really wanted to get the
first season right and yes I think that
without going into anything specific
that I think fans of the show after they
get through the first season are gonna
want more okay perhaps with the wave let
me say it like that okay well we would
like that I'd like to find out what
happens and I'd like to know yeah sure
but I'd really need to know I'm like I
write some fanfiction send it to you
you're gonna do you do Yelp reviews for
this forever you know you don't ok I
can't go on Yelp and be like this shows
fantastic that's not gonna make an
effect for next year like I can see when
you spend extra time online yes a few
random questions since we have to avoid
spoilers what for each of you what TV
show would you love to guest star on oh
I really Will and Grace and I'm gonna
tell you they look like they're having
such an incredibly fun time and to me at
47 years old having done this for
40-something years I just want to be
around people that make me laugh and
that I have a good time
I'm sorry we didn't laugh we laughed a
lot we also cried a lot well yeah we
okay so it wasn't like that I didn't
love our experience it was just I think
no I don't love grace more I just I
think I just want to go giggle for like
three days and then and then go home
just giggle for three days and then go
home especially after this which was
really intense but also giggly I want to
be a wheel of fortune does that count
collect your percentage counts can't be
on wheel of fortune if you want to
I love wheel of fortune too I was picked
to be on wheel of fortune one time but
then I got my first acting job at the
same on the same network I never got to
be on wheel of fortune I can't believe
it I have been on The Price is Right and
the family here I think it's amazing the
truth ultra what is that what is it the
show that Rob Lowe is doing right now
with the ninja thing oh my god it's
fantastic I love my daughter loves it
and well I won't do it because I don't
want anybody else see how bad I am at
that but
that's my fantasy my last question for
you guys do you remember your first
movie or TV show crush Don Johnson
Miami Vice that was very fast I took a
picture with a cardboard cutout when I
was on vacation with my family in Hawaii
with him I brought it back to school it
was a Polaroid
the dude from Greece - I know who you're
talking about caulfield something called
Maxwell Caulfield no come on now that's
what Goodman who are you goosh um thank
you so much
Congrats on the show I hope you get to
make my episodes